welcome to artificial intelligence
tutorial my name is Richard Kirchner I'm
with the simply learned team that's WWMT
learn comm get certified get ahead
what's in it for you today what is
artificial intelligence so we'll start
with the general concept types of
artificial intelligence covering the
four main areas ways of achieving
artificial intelligence and some general
applications of artificial intelligence
in today's world finally we'll dive into
a use case predicting if a person has
diabetes or not and we'll be using
tensorflow for that in the Python
environment what is artificial
intelligence in today's world is
probably one of the most exciting
advancements that we're in the middle of
experiencing as humans so what is
artificial intelligence and here we have
a robot with nice little clampy hands
hey what am i you are what we call
artificial intelligence I am your
Creator reminding him who programmed
them and who he's supposed to take care
of artificial intelligence is a branch
of computer science dedicated to
creating intelligent machines that work
and react like humans in today's place
where we're at with artificial
intelligence I really want to highlight
the fact that they work and react like
humans because that is where the
development of artificial intelligence
is and that's what we're comparing it to
is how it looks like next to a human
thanks any tasks you want me to do for
you get me a cup of coffee poof here you
go
and he brings him a cup of coffee that's
my kind of robot I love my coffee in the
morning you'll see there's kind of a
side theme of coffee today's tutorial so
here we have a robot that's able to
bring him a cup of coffee seems pretty
far out there you know that we have a
walking robot that's doing this but it's
not as far out there as you think we
have automatic coffee pots we have
devices that can move an object from one
point to the other you know anything
from Amazon delivering packages or
whatever you want all these things are
in today's world we're right on the edge
of all this that's what makes this so
exciting such an exciting topic and a
place of study so let's take a look a
real general look at types of artificial
intelligence in the really big picture
I mean we drill into it there's like
machine learning and all kinds of
different aspects but just a generic
level of artificial intelligence so hi
there discovered four different types
come have a look
so we have our kind of Einstein looking
guy or professor at some college so the
very first part that we're really this
is reactive machines they've been around
a long time this kind of AI are purely
reactive and do not hold the ability to
form memories or use past experiences to
make decisions these machines are
designed to do specific jobs remember I
talked about the programmable coffee
maker that makes coffee in the morning
it doesn't remember yesterday from
tomorrow it runs its program even going
back to our washing machines they have
automatic load balancers that have been
around for decades so reactive machines
we program to do certain tasks and they
have no memory but they're very
functional then we have limited memory
and this is kind of right where we're at
right now this kind of AI uses past
experience and the present data to make
a decision self-driving cars are kind of
limited memory AI we bring up
self-driving cars because that's a big
thing especially in today's market they
have all these images that they brought
in and videos of what's gone on before
and they use that to teach the automatic
car what to do so it's based on a
limited memory limited memory means it's
not evolving new ideas they have to
actually when they need to make a change
they have the program is built on the
memory but then they have to make those
changes outside of that and then put the
new setup in there so it's continually
reprogramming itself theory of mind
these AI machines can socialize and
understand human emotions machines with
such abilities are yet to be developed
of course that's under debate there's a
lot of places that are working on the
theory of mind and having it be able to
cognitively understand somebody based on
the environment their facial features
all kinds of things and evolve with them
so their own they have some kind of
reflective ability to evolve with that
and finally self-awareness this is a
future of AI these machines will be
super intelligent sentient and conscious
so they'll be able to react very much
like a human being although they'll have
their own
flavor I'm sure achieving artificial
intelligence so how in today's world
right now are we going to achieve
artificial intelligence
well the main arena right now is machine
learning machine learning provides
artificial intelligence with the ability
to learn this is achieved by using
algorithms to discover patterns and
generate insights from the data they are
exposed to and here we have a computer
as we get more and more to the human
realm of artificial intelligence
you see this guy splits in two and he's
inside his hidden networks and machine
learning programs deep learning which is
a subcategory of machine learning deep
learning provides artificial
intelligence the ability to mimic a
human brains neural network it can make
sense of patterns noise and sources of
confusion in the data let's try to
segregate different kinds of photos
using deep learning so first we have our
pile of photographs much more organized
in my boxes in my closet of photographs
the machine goes through the features of
every photo to distinguish them this is
called feature extraction bingo it
figures out the different features in
the photos and so based on those
different features labels of photos it
says these are landscapes these are
portraits these are others so it
separates them in there if you've ever
been on Google photos I'm a favorite of
mine I go through there and I type in
dog and I get all the images of my dog
it's pretty amazing how it's able to
pull those features out so when we're
achieving artificial intelligence and
the deep learning let's take a closer
look and see just how deep learning
works there are a lot of models out
there this is the most basic model used
this is a neural network there are three
main layers in a neural network the
photos that we want to segregate go into
the input layer and so we have a picture
of Mona Lisa it looks like in a couple
of people when it goes into the first
input layer the arrows are drawn into
like individual dots each one of those
white dots and the yellow layer in the
input layer would be a pixel in the
picture maybe a value for that pixel so
the picture of the mountains goes in
there and it fills in that whole input
layer and then the next picture or the
nightscape goes in there the hidden
layers are responsible for all the
mathematical computations or feature
extraction on our inputs
you see here we have the two kind of
orangish red layers here and there's all
these lines in there those lines are the
weights each one of those represents a
usually a float number or a decimal
number and then it multiplies it by the
value in the input layer and you'll see
that as it adds all these up in the
hidden layer each one of those dots in
the hidden layer that has a value based
on the sum of the weights and then it
takes those and puts it into another
hidden layer and you might ask well why
do we have multiple hidden layers
well the hidden layers function as
different alternatives to some degree so
the more hidden layers you have the more
complex the data that goes in and what
can they can produce coming out the
accuracy of the predicted output
generally depends on the number of
hidden layers we have so there we go
the accuracy is based on how many hidden
layers we have and again it has to do
with how complex the data is going in
the output layer gives us the segregated
photos so once it adds up all these
weights and you'll see there's weights
also going into the output layer based
on those weights it'll say yes it's a
portrait no it's a portrait yes it's a
landscape no it's a landscape and that's
how we get our setup in there so now we
were able to label our photos let's take
a look and see what that looks like in
another domain we have photograph domain
now let's look at it in the airline
ticket so let's predict the airline
ticket prices using machine learning
these are the factors based on which
we're going to make the predictions and
choosing your factors is so important
but for right here we'll just go ahead
and take a look what we got
we have Airlines we have the origin
airport the destination Airport the
departure date here are some historical
data of ticket prices to train the
machine so we pull in the old data this
is what's happened over the years now
that our machine is trained let's give
it new data for which it will predict
the prices if we remember from our four
different kinds of machines we have
machines with memory well this is the
memory part it remembers all the old
data and then it compares what you put
in to produce the new data to predict
the new prices the price is 1,000
that's an expensive flight of course if
that is a US dollars if it's India I
don't know what the price range is on
that hopefully it's a good deal wherever
you're going so we predict the prices
and this is
nice because if you're looking lay ahead
it'd be nice to know if you're planning
a trip for next year how much those
tickets are gonna cost and they
certainly fluctuate a lot so let's take
a look at the applications of artificial
intelligence we're gonna dive just a
little deeper cuz we talked about photos
we've talked about airline ticket prices
kind of very specific you get one
specific number but let's look at some
more things that are probably more
in-home more common right now
speaking of in-home this young gentleman
is entering his room of course makes a
comment like we all do we walk into a
room this room is dark isn't it let's
see what happens when I enter it the
sensors in my room detect my presence
and switch on the lights this is an
example of non memory machines okay you
know it senses you it doesn't have a
memory whether you got it or not some of
the new models start running a
prediction as to whether you're in the
room or not when you show up when you
don't so they turn things on before you
come down the stairs in the morning
especially if you're trying to save
energy might have one of those fancy
thermostats which starts guessing when
you get up in the morning so it doesn't
start the heater until it knows you're
gonna get up so here he comes in here
and this is one of the examples of smart
machine and that is one of the many
applications of artificial intelligence
one of the things we're developing here
in our homes okay bye
abruptly he leaves leaving his nice
steaming cup of coffee there on the
table and when he leaves the sensors
detect he's gone and turn off the lights
let's watch some TV did someone say TV
the sound sensors on the TV detect my
voice and turn on the TV sounds kind of
strange but with the Google dongle and a
Google home mini you can actually do
just that you can ask it to play a movie
downstairs on your downstairs TV true
also with the Amazon fire stick and all
the different artificial intelligent
home appliances that are coming out
pretty amazing time to be alive and in
this industry
here you have one more application of
artificial intelligence and you can
probably think of dozens of others and
are right now on the cutting edge of
development so let's jump into my
favorite part which is a use case
predict if a person has diabetes and in
the medical domain if you read any of
these ACA predict
a person has diabetes but in the medical
domain we would want to restate this as
what is the risk is a person high risk
of diabetes it should just be something
on their radar to be looking out for and
we'll be helping you out with the use
case there we are with a cup of coffee
again I forgot to shave as you can see
we'll start with the problem statement
the problem statement is to predict if a
person has diabetes or not and we might
start with this prediction statement but
if you were actually using this in real
case again you would say your high risk
of diabetes would be the proper way to
present that to somebody if you ran
their test data through here but that's
very domain-specific which is outside of
the problem statement as far as the
computer programmers involved so we can
have a look at the features these are
the things that have been recorded and
they already have this data from the
hospitals one of them would be number of
times pregnant obviously if you're a guy
that'd be zero glucose concentration so
these are people have had their glucose
measured blood pressure age age is a big
factor an easy thing to look at insulin
level so if someone's on insulin they
probably have diabetes otherwise they
wouldn't be taking insulin but that
would affect everything else and we add
that in there if they're if they're
using insulin let's start off with the
code so we're gonna start off by
importing parts of our data set and if
we're gonna do this let's jump in to one
of our favorite tools we're gonna use
the Anaconda Jupiter notebook so let me
flip over to there and we'll talk just
briefly about that and then we'll look
over this code so here we are in the
Jupiter notebook and this is an inline
editor which is just really cool for
messing with Python on the fly you can
do demos in it it's very visual you can
add pieces of code it has cells so you
can run each cell individually you can
delete them you can tell the cell to be
a comment so that instead of running it
it just skips over it it's all kinds of
cool things you can do with Jupiter
notebook we're not gonna go into that
we're actually gonna go with the tensor
flow and you do have to import all the
different modules in your Python now if
you're in a different Python IDE that's
fine they'll work in just about any of
your Python IDs and I'll point out the
one difference in code when we get to
that which is the in line for doing our
graph and in this code we're going to go
through we're going to load our data up
we're going to explore it we're going to
lay
and then we'll use the tensorflow and
then we'll get down to the end where
we're gonna take a look at how good the
model is does it work so let's start
with the top part here and let me go
ahead and let's paste that code in there
I've added a line in at the top I've
added the folder because I didn't put it
in the same folder as the program that's
running you don't need to worry too much
about that but if you have a folder
issue or says file doesn't exist you
probably have it in the wrong folder or
you need to add the folder path and then
we're gonna import pandas let me just
when the cool thing since it's in
Internet Chrome we can just do that ctrl
+ + zoom right in there and we have the
import pandas as PD so go ahead and draw
a line of there you can see that the
pandas as PD add a little drawing thing
in there to make it easier to see pandas
is a data set it's a really nice package
you can add into your Python usually
it's done as pandas as PD that's very
common to see the PD here circle that
it's basically like an Excel spreadsheet
it adds columns it adds some headers it
adds a lot of functionality to look at
your data and the first thing we're
gonna do with that is we're gonna come
down here and we're gonna read this is a
CSV it's a CSV file you can open up the
file on your computer if you want if you
need access to the file you can either
search it and download it from the main
thing or type a note in down below on
the YouTube video and simply learn we'll
help you get that file also and that's
true of any questions you have on this
you can add comments down there and
somebody has simply learn actually keeps
an eye on that I'll try to answer those
questions for you I put in the full path
you don't have to if you have your data
file saved in the same folder you're
running your program in and this is just
a CSV file comma separated variables and
with the pandas we can read it in there
and we're gonna give it put it right in
a variable called diabetes and then
finally we take diabetes and you'll see
diabetes dot head this is a pandas
command and it's really nice because it
just displays the data for us let me go
ahead and erase that let's say we go up
to the Run button up here in our Jupiter
notebook which runs the script in this
that's it cell we're in and you can see
with the diabetes ahead since it's a
panda's data frame it prints everything
out nice and neat for us and this is
really great and if I go ahead and do a
control - I can get it all to fit on the
same screen
and this is the first
five lines when you do the head of the
data just prints out the first five
lines in programming of course we start
with zero so we have 0 1 2 3 & 4 there
we go yeah here we go we start with 0 we
have 0 1 2 3 & 4 we have our titles
going across the top and of course the
first column is number of pregnancies
glucose concentration for the second one
blood pressure measurements of triceps
as we keep going you'll see you can
guess what most of these things are
group I'm not sure this is probably the
test group
I didn't look it up to see specifically
what that is anytime you start exploring
data for this example we don't really
need to get too much in detail you want
to know the domain what does this
information mean are we
duplicating information going in that's
beyond the scope of this for right now
though we're just gonna look at this
data and we're gonna take apart the
different pieces of this data so let's
jump in there and take a look at what
the next set of code is so in our next
setup or our next step we gotta start
looking at cleaning the data we got
start looking at these different columns
and how are we gonna bring them in which
columns are what I'm gonna jump ahead a
little bit and also as we look at the
columns we're gonna do our import our
tensor flow as TF that's a common import
that's our tensor flow model tensor flow
was developed by Google and then they
put it into open source so that it's
free for everybody to use which is
always a nice thing so let's take a look
at what these two steps look like in our
Jupiter notebook so it's paces code in
here and this is something that happens
when you're messing with data is you'll
repeat yourself numerous times we
already have diabetes head so I'm going
to put the little pound sign which tells
python that this is just going to be a
comment we're not gonna run it a second
time in here we have diabetes dot
columns and then diabetes columns two
norm equals diabetes columns two norm
not apply lambda X let's talk about that
but let me first run that and let's see
what that comes out with that and then
let's put the next set of code in also
and I'm gonna run that let me just hit
the Run button and it doesn't really
have an output but we did a lot of stuff
here so let's go over what we did on
this so I've turned on my drawing
implement to help cope through all this
there's a lot going on here the
first thing is we have all of our
columns up here all of our column names
let me just highlight that and draw a
circle around that like we did earlier
and we want to look at just specific
columns and we're gonna start let me
change the color on this so it really
sticks out just like blue I'm gonna look
at these columns and we're not gonna do
age class or group we're gonna look at
those in a different way and I'll
explain a little bit what that's about
so we're looking at number of
pregnancies
glue basically anything that can be read
as a float number and you might say age
could be read as a float number we're
gonna address that differently
because when you're doing statistics we
usually take the ages and we group them
into buckets and we'll talk about that
and so we're gonna take these columns
and we're going to do what they call
normalize ohm's column to normalize what
is normalize if you're using the SK
learn module one of their neural
networks they call it scaling or scaler
this is in all of these neural networks
what happens is if I have two pieces of
data and let's say one of them is in
this case zero to six and one of them is
in insulin level is zero to maybe 0.2
would be a very high level I don't know
what they actually go to a neural
network well look at the six and it'll
go zero to six and as you get into zero
six here's an eight even a higher number
it will weight those heavier and so ill
skew the results based more on the
number of pregnancies than based on the
insulin or based on the blood pressure
so we want to level the playing field we
want these values to all be in the same
area we do that by normalizing it here
and we use a lambda function this is
always a kind of a fun thing we take the
diabetes it's a panda setup and let me
just erase all that so we can go down
here put it back to red and we take our
diabetes which is a panda data set and
we only want to look at the columns to
normalize because that's what we built
we built a list of those columns and
we're going to apply a lambda function
and you'll see lambda and all kinds of
Python programming it just means it's a
function we put X in and whatever is
outside of the X over here it then takes
that
and returns that value so the new value
is going to be whatever X is minus X Men
again it's a panda's data set so we can
get by with that which is really cool
makes it easy to read so we take X we
look for the minimum value of X and then
we divide that by the maximum value X
minus the X Men or the width and what
this essentially does is if you're going
from 0 to 15 it's gonna divide by 15 and
then we subtract it let's MIT let's make
this to mr. to 0 or 20 22 115 there we
go first off we set this to 0 so we
subtract X min so right off the bat the
minimal value is going to be 0 and then
we divide it by the difference here X
min minus X Max or x max minus X min
this basically sets all the values
between 0 to 1 and that's very important
if we want to make sure that it's not
going to be a skew and the results if
it's not gonna weight the values one
direction or the other 0 to 1 that's
what this is doing and again there's
like so many different ways to scale our
data this is the most basic scale a
standard scaling and it's the most
common and we spelled it out in the
lambda you can there's actual modules to
do that but lambda is just such an easy
thing to do and you can see really see
what we're doing here
so now we've taken these columns we've
scaled them all and changes them to a
zero to one value we now need to let the
program know the tensorflow model that
we're gonna create we need to let it
know what these things are so to do that
I create a variable called number
pregnancy
keep it simple and we've imported the
tensor flow as TF one line of code
brings our tents our flow in for us
awesome love Python so you get number of
pregnancies and TF dot feature column
dot numeric column we're gonna tell it's
a numeric column so notice that this is
a float value 0 to 1 and then number
underscore pregnant so we're taking that
column we've reshaped that column from 0
to 1 and no that doesn't mean you have a
point 1 pregnancy it just means 0 0.1
equals 1 or something
number pregnant so we're just mapping
this data so tensorflow knows what to do
with it and we go through all of these
we go through all the way up to again
we're not doing age let me just separate
H down here these have all been adjusted
age we're gonna handle differently we
still put it as a numerical column
because it is so let me just circle age
and group we didn't even touch group yet
we're gonna look at group and age and
we're gonna do some special stuff with
that class we're gonna look at last why
because this is whether they have
diabetes or not that's what we're
testing for so this is our history you
know these people have diabetes or not
and we want to find out we want to
create a model and then we want to test
that model predicting whether somebody
new has diabetes or not so here I am
still with my cup of coffee working away
refill number three
let's explore both the categorical group
which is going to be the ABC and D on
the end and also the age we're going to
talk about those a little bit more and
then we're gonna combine all those
features and we'll jump into splitting
the data although that's kind of the
next step we'll put that all together
what are we doing with the age and what
are we doing with the group down there
so let's flip on over and take a look at
our Jupiter notebook so the first thing
is this put this new set of code in here
and run it and let's talk about what
we're doing on this set of code in I
actually want to go one more step
forward on the Nix at a code or part of
it there we go and I'm going to just run
that while we have it that's fine let's
just scroll up a little bit here and
let's go through what we just did with
this set of code if we go back up here
to the top part we have Group B CBBC we
learned from the header so when I come
down here we're gonna create assigned
group and let me get my drawing pad out
so we're looking at this first one up
here assigned group TF feature column
categorical column with vocabulary list
that is a mouthful this is saying that
this is a categorical list in this case
we have ABCD you see this a lot in
tensor flow a lot of times tensor flow
is used to analyze text or logs error
logs and they're just full of all this
information and they take these in this
case ABCD but in other cases it'd be
words and they create numbers out of
them so it has zero this is one column
this is another column this is another
column this is another column and it's
just this way of being able to look at
this in a different light assigning them
different values you really don't want
to assign this a float
value first thought might be let's
assign this zero to three zero one two
three four ABCD but if you did that it
would try to add 1 plus 2 to get 3 as
part of its math and functions and that
just isn't true C does not equal a plus
B C is just a categorical name it could
have been the Frank group and Laura's
group and a bids group but it's not you
know these are they're not float numbers
so very important you have that
distinction in your data the next step
we're looking at is our map plot and
we're gonna do this this is a cool
useful tool we're gonna import map plot
library type lot as PLT a standard
import and this next line here is really
important we're doing the map plot
library we want it to be in line that's
because we're in a jupiter notebook
remember i told you before that if
you're running this in a different ide
you might get a different results this
is the line you need if you want to see
the graph on this page and then we do
diabetes we're gonna look at just the
age and dot hist bins equals 20 what the
heck is that well it turns out that
because this is remember it's a pandas
there's our PD pandas as PD because it's
as a pandas panda automatically knows to
look for the map plot library and a hist
it just means it's gonna be a histogram
and we're gonna separate it into 20 bins
and that's what this graph is here so
when I take the diabetes and I do a
histogram of it it produces this really
nice graph we can see that at 22 most of
the participants in this probably around
174 of the people that were recorded
were of this age bracket they're right
here in this this first column here and
as they get further and further down
they have less and less and less until
when you're at 80 you can actually see
down here there's almost none in a
couple of these categories and this is
important to know because when you're
doing census you know the older the the
group is the more of the people have
passed away so you're gonna have this in
any of your senses as you take you're
always gonna have a much larger group in
the younger crowd and then it gets lower
and lower as they get older and I
mentioned the word buckets here we go
we're gonna create an age bucket we're
gonna put people in buckets can you
imagine people sitting in buckets kind
of a funny way of looking at it this
just makes it easier for us to separate
it when I go into the dock
office I don't want to be told well your
h22
this is you know you'll get a decent one
at 22
here we are back to my cup of coffee I
told you coffee was an underlying theme
these next couple steps are very
specific to tensorflow
up until now we had some tensorflow as
we set the categories up but you'd have
to set that up with any model you use to
make sure they're set correctly they'd
be set up a little differently but we
run input functions and in tensorflow
this allows for some really cool things
to happen and this is why tensorflow is
so predominant in a lot of areas so
let's take a look at these next couple
lines of code here we're gonna create
the input function and we're gonna go
ahead and create the model and let me go
ahead and put these codes in here I went
ahead and split it up so as different
lines we could talk a little bit about
that and then the actual model and let
me go ahead and run this so we can see
what that looks like and in my
particular environment it just prints
out a little bit of information about
the model not too worried about looking
at that but we do want to take a closer
look at what we did here so we've
created an input function and again this
is very specific to tensorflow with the
input function we have our train we have
our x equals x train and our y equals y
train because we want to train it with
the particular information but we have
these other settings in here these two
settings and the number of epochs is how
many times it's going to go over our
training model epoch means large that
means all the data so we're gonna go
over at a thousand times that's actually
a huge overkill for this amount of data
usually it only needs probably about 200
but you know when we're putting it
together and you're trying things out
you just kind of throw the numbers in
there then you go back and fine-tune it
sometimes the batch size is really
important this is where tensorflow
does some really cool things if you're
processing this over a huge amount of
data and you try to batch everything at
once you end up with a problem this
means we're only gonna read 10 lines at
a time through our data so each one of
those rows of testing they've done we're
only going to look at ten of them at a
time and put that through our model and
train it and then shuffles
self-explanatory we're just moving we're
just randomly selecting which data and
what order we go in that way if there's
like you know five in a row that are
kind of weighted one way and vice versa
it mixes them up and then finally we
create our model so the model goes in
there and goes okay I have a TF
estimated linear classifier we're gonna
put in the feature columns equal
your columns we defined all our columns
up above and then we have in classes
equal to and that just means we have our
out result is 0 or 1 you have diabetes
or you don't have diabetes or in this
case we actually call it high risk of
diabetes and then I put one more line of
code in there which I forgot we've set
up our model we set up our feature
columns know we need to actually train
it model dot train you'll see this so
common in so many different neural
network models this is like a standard
what's different though is we have to
feed it the function remember we created
this function with all this information
on it and then we have steps and steps
similar to number of batches and batch
size it's more like individual lines we
step through a thousand is a lot more
common for steps than epics but steps is
used you'd probably leave this out in
this particular example and let's go
ahead and run this all together
because it has a site when we start
training it we get a different output so
here we go I've run it it's given me the
information from when I'm created the
model and now it just starts going
through we get this information tensor
loss equals global step all kinds of
stuff going on here and if you're
following this it's just going through
the steps in training it it gives you
information it could dig deep into here
but for this particular setup we're not
gonna go too deep on what's going on
just know that we've trained our model
this model now has the information we
need in it to start running predictions
so as we sip our next take our next step
of coffee or maybe it's tea or if you're
one of those dreams late-night workers
maybe it's a sip of wine we go into the
next step and we actually want to run
some predictions on here but we don't
want to run the training we want to run
the test on there we want to take our
test data and see what it did and
suppose we're gonna do next is we're
gonna run the test through and actually
get some answers so if you were actually
deploying it you would pull the answers
out of the data it's bringing back let's
take a look at that in our Jupiter
notebook so here we go let's paste it in
there I'm gonna go ahead and run it and
you'll see that as it goes it's actually
putting the answers out if you remember
correctly well walk through this here in
just a second but it goes through and it
runs each line and it gives you a
prediction for each line one at a time
and prints them out so let's take a look
and see what that actually looks like
let's start with this first part we've
another function this is just like the
other function except for x equals x
test and there's no why why is there no
y because we don't know what the answer
is on this yet we don't want to tell it
the answer we wanted to guess what the
answer is so we can evaluate that and
see how good it did on that 33% of the
data so this is our X test batch size is
10 again so if we were watching this
roll down here we would see that it
actually processes at 10 lines at a time
it's only going to go through once it
goes through all the X test data one
time we don't need to have it predict
multiple times and shuffle equals false
very important we set the shuffle to
false because if we were tracking this
and actually giving people answers we'd
want to make sure it connects to the
right person so they get the right
results of course we're just doing this
to evaluate it so let's take a look down
here what I put out and as I scroll down
to my jupiter notebook we have some
information as far as a tensor flow
running and then the actual output and
if we look at the output we know by this
first bracket in python it's an array we
know by this squiggly bracket that this
is a dictionary so that this is a label
the dictionary has logistic
probabilities class IDs classes and so
this whole first part let me redo that
this whole first part is one output and
we know that because there is the
bracket there and there is this bracket
here for the dictionary and it's a
dictionary of terms so if I pulled this
out and I looked at object 0 in here I
would go down to let me just find it
here it is classes remember how we
defined classes we defined classes as
our answer and so it's guessing our
tensorflow says based on all the
information you gave me I'm guessing
this first entry of our first test data
is high-risk diabetes oh go get tested
change your diet watch what you're
eating you know high risk one and if we
go down far enough we can see down here
is another one where classes equals zero
I skipped a couple because they're all
ones up here the B this particular
output B in front of the 1 means it's a
binary output it only comes out as 0 or
1 and there's a lot of other information
in here you can dig deep into tensorflow
and explain these different numbers
that's way beyond the scope of what
we're working on today so the basics of
it though is you get an output we have
an output of whether the person has
diabetes or not well in this case it's
high risk of diabetes or not so now that
we've run our predictions take a sip of
coffee and a short break and we say well
what do we need to do well we need to
know how good was our predictions we
need to evaluate our model so if you're
gonna publish this to a company or
something like that they want to know
how good you did let's take a look at
what that looks like in the code so
let's paste that in here and just real
quick go back over this by now this
function should look very this is an e
we're gonna call it eval input function
it's be pretty straightforward here we
have our TF estimator inputs pandas
input function and then we have our X
test our Y test this time we want to
give it the answer so it has something
to see how good at it on batches 10
processing 10 at a time or let go once
through the data
we're not shuffling it although it
doesn't really matter with this and then
we're gonna do results equals model dot
evaluate we put our evaluation function
in there this should all look familiar
so repeating the same thing it's very
similar with a couple different changes
as far as what we're feeding it and the
fact that we're doing an evaluation
let's see what that looks like we run it
and we go up here to our run model
you'll see warnings on some of these
because I didn't install this on its own
install so a lot of it is this temporary
files because I'm using the Jupiter
notebook instead of setting it up on a
regular machine and we get our output
and we'll go ahead and just look at this
output real quick and then we'll flip
over and from here you'll see that it
generates an accuracy a baseline average
loss the mean gives you a precision
prediction it gives you all kinds of
information on here so let's flip over
and see what's important and we'll look
at the slide here we are in this slide
and this should be exciting because we
just about wrapped up our whole tensor
flow and tensor flow is one of the more
complicated models out there so give
yourself a pat on the back for getting
all the way through this when we look at
this output we have an accuracy of 0.7 1
6 5 that's really what we want to look
at that means that we have an accuracy
if you're just truncating it of 71%
that's quite good for our model you know
give it a small amount of data we came
up with a 71 percent of letting people
know they're high risk
or not with diabetes so we created a
model that can predict if a person has
diabetes based on some previous records
of people who were diagnosed with
diabetes and we managed to have an
accuracy of 71% which is quite good the
model was implemented on Python using
tensorflow
again pat yourself on the back because
tensorflow is one of the more
complicated scripts out there it's also
one of the more diverse and useful ones
so the key takeaways today is we've
covered what is artificial intelligence
with a robot that brings us coffee and
we noted that we are comparing it to how
it reacts and looks like humans very
important to note that in today's world
where we're at and we looked at types of
artificial intelligence from the
reactive machines to limited memory and
looking into the future of theory of
mind and self-awareness then we went in
there and took a look at taking photos
and how artificial machine learning work
we took a glance at deep learning with
our neural networks and how we have
hidden layers and our input layer and
our output layer we didn't looked at a
use case of somebody walking into a room
and activating their TV using artificial
intelligence or part of the AI category
and finally we dug in deep and we did
some coding in the tensor flow in Python
with that let's wrap it up I'd like to
thank you for joining us today for more
information visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here